écoutez on vous a distribué le document
je vais parcourir rapidement si vous
voulez bien c'est une travail qui a été
réalisé en peu de temps mais la droite
avait travaillé pendant la droite et le
centre travaillé pendant deux ans
quasiment d'arrache-pied sur les sur les
projets donc l'idée était de regarder
comment pouvoir créer une nouvelle
cohérence dans un projet législatif non
pas à partir uniquement du projet de
françois fillon mais à partir de ce qui
avait été dit par les uns et par les
autres
en partenariat avec nos amis de l'udf
avec lesquels nous avons beaucoup
travaillé c'est clairement un projet
pour faire réussir la france et c'est
clairement un projet qui s'inscrit dans
l'idée que notre pays pour réussir doit
évidemment atteindre le plein emploi
on garde donc cet objectif majeur qui
est celui de la compétitivité des
entreprises
on garde l'idée du cic e transformé en
baisse de charge
on ajoute une diminution de charges
patronales au delà et d'impôts de
production ont réduit modifie allège le
code du travail peut répondre aux
questions que vous souhaitez évidemment
tout ça et détaillés dans le document
voilà c'est un projet qui est clairement
tourné vers l'entreprise et sa capacité
à créer à la fois du pouvoir d'achat à
la fois de la distribution des richesses
est évidemment de l'emploi en france on
n'oublie pas d'ailleurs que des
entreprises françaises sont assez en
retard dans le domaine de de la
digitalisation et on a beaucoup de
propositions de cette nature mais la clé
des choses c'est aussi de se dire que
les français ne doivent pas être oubliés
de cela est que nous devons faire un
geste un effort important pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français
et cet effort nous le faisons au travers
d'un certain nombre de mesures qui ne
sont pas que symbolique qui sont des
mesures importantes
la première c'est le fait que nous
n'augmenterons pas la tva françois
fillon avait proposé de le faire il
avait évolué sur le sujet mais nous
avons finalement décidé de ne pas le
faire nous n'augmenterons pas la tva
pourquoi parce que il ya un discours un
peu contradictoires de considérer qu'il
faut baisser les prélèvements
obligatoires et de l'autre
augmenter la tva qui touchait 2
de près de directement les français donc
nous avons revu les choses là-dessus et
la base est tout à fait clair en face de
cela
emmanuel macron ils augmentent
massivement les impôts ils augmentent
il ya une augmentation cacher des impôts
chez emmanuel macron parce que personne
n'est vraiment insister sur le sujet
peut-être parce qu'il ya pas eu de débat
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
est peut-être parce qu'il faut installer
ce débat maintenant celles assiégées
l'augmentation de la csg c'est plus de
20 milliards d'euros
ces 20 milliards d'euros frappe
directement les retraités les
fonctionnaires les professions libérales
et d'une certaine façon aussi même si
une baisse de cotisations sociales
salariales probablement un certain
nombre de salariés donc 20 milliards
d'euros
au-delà de ces 20 milliards d'euros il
ya aussi ce que veut faire
emmanuel macron en ce qui concerne les
contrats d'assurance vie dont qu' une
augmentation de l'impôt des contrats
d'assurance vie et puis en préparation
semble t'il une augmentation très forte
de l'imposition de l'immobilier pour
essayer de compenser ce que propose
emmanuel macron sur cette suppression en
partie partiel et peu efficace de la
taxe d'habitation
donc nous avons la volonté de baisser
les impôts impôt sur le revenu également
l'impôt sur le revenu baissera de 10 %
les heures sup sujet qui a été abordé
mille fois durant la campagne sujet
qu'on a abordé dans chaque entreprise
dans chaque usine qu'on pouvait visiter
c'est un consensus qui s'est dégagé
autour de l'idée que nous déchargeront
et défiscalisant les heures
supplémentaires
je vous ai je passerai peut-être sur des
points de de détails
il ya évidemment l'idée de stabilité
fiscale qui est extrêmement importante
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
fixe des règles du jeu il ira si le
premier ministre le décide un collectif
budgétaire dès l'été et dès l'été nous
fixerons les règles du jeu sur le plan
fiscal à partir de ce qui a été dit et
puis partir de ce que vous lirez dans le
document et nous stabiliserons ses
règles pour rendre la france plus
attractif au-delà de ces sujets nous
avons voulu aussi insistez beaucoup sur
les sujets
régalien qui sont extrêmement lourds
très préoccupant pour les français on
souhaite évidemment aboutir une impunité
zéro pour les délinquants on renforce
voir les polices municipales on
renforcera les places de prison ray
instaurera les pannes de plancher les
peines planchers automatique on restera
les peines planchers automatique
on supprimera toutes les réductions
celle-ci automatique de deux peines
on inscrira la majorité pénale des
mineurs récidivistes
à 16 ans on continuera la guerre très
très très lourde contre le terrorisme en
liaison avec damman avec nos avec nos
alliés mais par exemple en ce qui
concerne les fichiers s ils seront
placés de manière préventive sous sûr
pour les plus dangereux à partir de cela
sous surveillance physique et
électronique renforcée on expulse sera
automatiquement les étrangers en
situation en situation de de relations
avec les mouvance salafiste
on augmentera la capacité et la qualité
du renseignement français enfin bref
beaucoup de sujets que vous découvrirez
également dans ceux dans ce texte
objectif important réduire de moitié le
l'immigration sur le quinquennat c'est
un point qui est fondamental
chaque année parlement votera des quotas
concernant l'immigration
on créera des zones de contrôles
renforcés dans les lieux de tensions sur
les questions d'immigration on pense
évidemment à calais mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres lieux on réformera les
procédures de droit d'asile
bref un sujet aussi traiter de façon
complète la défense nous l'avions
indiqué déjà mais nous nous confirmons
les forfaits en fins en faveur de la
dépend des france à hauteur de 2% du
produit intérieur brut et nous nous en
confortons aussi les deux composantes
que sont du nucléaire français nous
voulons une france plus européenne et
plus souveraine et c'est un sujet qui me
semble extrêmement important la
souveraineté du pays
elle peut s'exprimer de différentes
manières d'abord une souveraineté
financière
nous confirmons l'objectif de 100
milliards d'euros de baisses de la
dépense publique
cet effort est appuyée sur une baisse du
nombre de fonctionnaires que nous ne
chiffrent ont pas à 500 milles en fin de
quinquennat mais à 300 milles nous
conservons l'objectif de 500 milles mais
ne leur portons de deux ans nous voulons
un pacte de progrès avec la fonction
publique
on parlera avec la fonction publique de
la nécessaire augmentation du temps de
travail est bien une augmentation du
temps de travail dans le projet
politique
nous négocierons avec les fonctionnaires
ou des vidéos seront aussi en fonction
de la qualité de vie et
des rémunérations de la nature des
rémunérations qui peuvent être portés il
peut pas y avoir de paupérisation des
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui l'idée que
l'on ne baissent automatiquement et tout
le temps le point à 10 tout con le gel
n'est évidemment pas une politique
d'avenir pour la fonction publique donc
faut remettre à plat les modes de
rémunérations de la fonction publique
nous avons beaucoup partagé avec lui des
i sur l'europe on veut une europe plus
forte
il n'y a pas de france forte sans europe
forte on essaye d indiquer en quoi cela
consiste
on intègre l'idée des contrats
commerciaux de la loyauté dans ces
contrats commerciaux dans ces traités
commerciaux on ajoute l'idée qu'on re
négociera la directive sur les
travailleurs détachés
lorsque quelqu'un travail en france le
salaire doit être français et les
charges doivent être également française
nous évoquons l'aide souveraineté
numérique c'est un sujet qui est souvent
sous les radars qui est un sujet
absolument essentiel pour l'avenir du
pays
enfin on indique que
nous signerons un contrat d'équité avec
tous les français pour essayer de
conserver notre modèle économique et
surtout notre propre modèle social je
pense particulièrement et au delà de la
sphère sociale nous voulons la retraite
à 65 ans progressivement nous voulons
que les français soient mieux remboursés
dans leur système de soins on explique
comment nous pensons qu'il ya des exclus
de la république dont on parle jamais ou
pas suffisamment que sont les handicapés
ou que ce sont encore les personnes en
situation de dépendance mais nous
concentrons les choses sur l'idée qu'il
peut pas y avoir deux poids deux mesures
en france particulièrement je pense à
l'équité territoriale
on a bien vu que les zones rurales voté
aujourd'hui largement au fond par des
espérances pour le front national
on doit essayer d'avoir un message clair
vis-à-vis des zones rurales et de la
ruralité française au delà même de
l'agriculture et nous appelons un
moratoire de la fermeture des services
publics en milieu rural
nous créons une agence d'égalité des
territoires et de redynamisation des
territoires et des zones rurales
nous parlons de l'accès au numérique
nous évoquons bref une ruralité ancré
dans la république c'est
particulièrement important
enfin la jeunesse souvent été oublié des
campagnes électorales
nous faisions un certain nombre de
propositions sur la genèse
spécifiquement nous proposons un contrat
avec la jeunesse de de france je pense
par exemple à l'idée de travailler mieux
avec les conseils régionaux état et
conseils régionaux pour faciliter la
mobilité professionnelle des jeunes que
ce soit une mobilité physique ou une
mobilité en termes d'emploi nous
évoquons l'accès au premier logement
qu'il soit locataire ou en forme de
propriété mais on a dit qu'un certain
nombre de mesures qui permettront je
l'espère 2 d'améliorer les conditions de
vie et d'entrer sur marché du travail
des jeunes de francs sans faille un
contrat sur la modernisation de la vie
publique la transparence de la vie
public évidemment nous baisserons le
nombre de parlementaires mais en même
temps pense qu'il faut plus de pouvoirs
et puis également les parlementaires
le parlement doit exercer totalement son
rôle il n'est pas question que le
parlement perde de sa puissance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement vis-à-vis du
président de la république on veillera à
tout cela et on explique comment
voilà un petit tour d'horizon d'un
projet cohérent globale qui évoquent
tous les points qui est un vrai projet
de gouvernement pour une nouvelle
majorité pour la france